all right so a massive amount of
information was just leaked and revealed
concerning apple silicon max and based
on everything i'm seeing
people are vastly underestimating how
good apple macs are about to become
so in this video i'm going to discuss
all of these leaks including the release
date
which max to expect first how much
performance we can realistically expect
and how well apps are already running on
the apple silicon
developer transition kit first off the
number one major benefit to apple
silicon max
that people are underestimating is the
fact that they'll be able to natively
run
iphone and ipad apps right out of the
box
and if you're struggling to figure out
how that's going to work developer steve
trout and smith was able to get them
working
on his apple developer transition kit
which uses the a12z
chip and so far he's extremely impressed
so i'll be talking about that in just a
minute and by the way
geekbench 5 pro is now running natively
on this new mac
and that a12z chip is getting very
impressive scores
in the multi-core test it scored 4555
points
which beats out the fastest 10th gen i7
processor
in the 2020 13 inch macbook pro and it
also scored 12
610 metal graphics points which again
is faster than that same macbook pro was
able to achieve
so the future is already looking very
bright for apple silicon max
and to make it even better nine to five
mac just revealed a major
exclusive leak from the latest mac os
big sur
beta 3 release they've basically found a
new extension with code
that points to apple silicon max finally
coming with face id
and this makes sense because face id
requires the neural engine
which is built into the iphone and the
ipad
and apple has already revealed that
apple silicon max
are gonna have the neural engine as well
so if this is true
future macs are gonna have access to
memoji features
and other augmented reality apps like
snapchat filters and things like that
now let's move on to the leak that
reveals when we should expect
the first apple silicon max to be
revealed it comes from the twitter page
ihack 2 which also reveals that apple's
iphone event
will be streamed online on september 8th
which includes air power and a new ipad
release
but our attention for this video is
apple's october event
which should be hosted on the 27th
and include a new ipad pro and two apple
silicon macs
the macbook and the 13-inch macbook pro
now i'm not exactly sure if apple will
be able to pack face id on those
macbooks
since they're fairly thin and small but
they will be packing the very first
apple silicon mac chips which will most
likely be
low power chips and then next year we
should begin to see
much more powerful versions of these
chips on the higher end max like the 16
inch macbook pro
now also seeing the ipad pro on that
leaked list
is a bit weird since apple just released
the 2020 ipad pro
and rumors are pointing to the new one
only coming in 2021
with a mini led display so it would be
awesome if apple was actually able to
get it done
sooner than expected and most likely
this new ipad pro
should feature the a14x chip which is
going to be built on
tsmc's new five nanometer fabrication
process and we actually have some very
recent performance leaks
that can help us figure out around how
much performance
that a14x chip will have in the past
apple's ipad pro chips were basically
more powerful versions of their iphone
chips
for example the a10x chip in the 2017
ipad pro
was about 61 percent more powerful than
the a10 chip
in the iphone 7 in terms of geekbench
5's
multi-core cpu test and then
interestingly
the a12 chip in the iphone 10s actually
outperformed
the a10x in the ipad pro and then the
a12x chip in the 2018 ipad pro
was about 71 percent more powerful than
the a12 chip in the iphone
with a score of 4606 points
and now we recently saw some leaked
benchmarks of the a14 ship
which is coming in this year's iphone 12
and it was able to achieve a score of 4
612 points which yet again
surprisingly beats the previous ipad pro
score
this basically shows us a trend in the
difference between the iphone chips and
the ipad pro chips
with around 61 to 71 more performance
so if we stick to a conservative 60
improvement coming from the leaked a14
chip score
and apply it to the a14x that we're
expecting in the upcoming ipad pro
then that gives us a massive multi-core
score
of 7 379
points this would mean that the upcoming
ipad pro
with that a14x chip could outperform
the best 8 core i9 9980 hk
processor in the 16 inch macbook pro
which scores around 6955 points
now while this might sound totally
insane you need to keep this in mind
that i9 chip is built using intel's
14 nanometer fabrication process which
actually compares pretty closely
to tsmc's 10 nanometer process
but you need to realize that the a14x
chip in the ipad pro
is going to be built using tsmc's brand
new
5 nanometer process so it's going to be
a lot more efficient
and it's going to run cooler than the i9
and now hold on to your seats because
it's about to get
a whole lot better that i9 chip has a
tdp
of 45 watts so let's go ahead and try
and figure out how much
the a14x will have the a10x chip in the
2017 ipad pro
has a tdp of 8 watts the a12x ship in
the 2018
ipad pro has a tdp of 15 watts
so there was an increase of 7 watts tdp
to go from 2268 multi-core score
to a massive 46.06 so if we assume that
the a14x chip
built on the new five nanometer process
will jump
up by the same seven watts tdp then we
can expect it to have a tdp of 22 watts
or maybe up to 25 watts just to give it
a little bit of wiggle room
now we have the 22 to 25 watt tdp
a14x chip outperforming
the best 45 watt intel i9 chip in the 16
inch macbook pro
which is absolutely insane and it
doesn't even end there
because keep in mind apple said that
their new apple silicon max are going to
come with a brand new
family of chips so they won't be using
the a14x
now why would they do this well these
new chips are going to be going into
macs
that have active fan cooling systems
this means that apple can design the
chips with
higher tdps so imagine if they scaled
the a14x chip
with more cores so that it brings up the
tdp
up from around 22 to 25 watts all the
way up to around
35 to 40 watts this would lead to
even more performance while still not
being quite as hot
as intel's current 45 watt chips now of
course
apple doesn't have to go all out like
this but they theoretically
can and in my personal opinion it makes
sense to do this because they need as
much attention as they can get
since there are a lot of people doubting
the switch
to apple silicon and to make all of this
even
better apple chip supply or tsmc is
already on their way to having mass
production
of their even better three nanometer
chips which will be shipping
in apple devices in 2022
which is ironic because intel literally
just delayed
their seven nanometer chips until 2022
or even
2023 causing their stock price to tank
by 16 today and to add salt to intel's
wounds
tsmc stock is now up 11
today and if all of this doesn't make
you excited for apple silicon max
let's now move on to what some
developers have to say about them
like the twitter user steve trout and
smith who says
ios and ipad apps are fully working
in beta 3 of mac os big sur he mentioned
that there
are a series of compatibility behaviors
applied to ios apps running
unmodified on mac os making them a lot
more likely
to work out of the box he also mentioned
that some previously missing
deprecated frameworks like opengl es
are now back in mac os so a lot of ios
apps should simply just work he also
said that full screen ipad apps
can now be resized between landscape and
portrait sizes
just fine with no broken layouts he then
said that it was fascinating
to see apps running totally unmodified
even with huge dependencies he showed
off procreate pocket working just fine
and the same for spotify and slack
running
perfectly and yes the youtube app and
google maps
were working as intended the only
downside he mentioned
is that developers can opt out of
running their apps on mac os
so there's a chance we might not see
every single app we want
on apple silicon max he also showed off
coding apps
like prompt continuous and pythonista
running
just fine he then mentioned that the
ipad version of pages
works perhaps a little too well with new
features like multiple windows
and open recent working as is he showed
off an ipad
chess game working great on mac os and a
more complex app
adobe draw working just fine as well he
got
overcast to work and mentioned that
it'll be allowed
to resize the app to arbitrary window
sizes
and as far as other developers hopper
should now
fully support apple silicon max and 925
mac was apparently able to get
instagram running just fine on their
developer transition kit there are also
a number of new code that's now
available for mac os
like on open url a new placeholder swift
ui
api which is apparently really good
and a new optional alternate view
controller tree
for the split view controller code and
apparently
all of this new code is going to improve
apps on ios
and ipad os 14 as well so basically
the point that i'm trying to make is
that all of these ios and ipad os
apps are already running on a mac while
being completely unmodified
using a beta version of mac os and on
apple's developer transition kit
now imagine how it's going to run when
everything is finally released
and developers have more time to
optimize their apps
to prepare for this and as far as
developers modifying their apps for
apple silicon
apple literally just released a brand
new tutorial series this morning
which helps developers build a native
mac app
from the same code base as an ipad app
this tutorial goes through things like
sidebar navigation
toolbar actions and ui refinements and
steve shouted out that this
is exactly what catalyst developers
needed
last year so basically what i'm trying
to say is that the future of the mac
is looking really bright right now and i
have a feeling that a lot of people are
going to be blown away at apple's
october 27th event when they finally
reveal
their very first apple silicon max and
give us more details on how
everything is going to work so hopefully
you learned something new from this
video
and if you did go ahead and tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe
be sure to check out our apple product
hoodie down below
and if you're interested in seeing how
gaming is gonna work on these new macs
definitely watch the video right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one